la plateforme il faut la sentir il faut
observer entendre et toucher tous les
garçons de photos de famille dans leur
bureau nous aussi on a demandé à avoir
des photos d'hommes nus et on a obtenu
celui là
[Musique]
mais l'effort
just je fais 30000 une de all out en
regardant des vidéos de ski ça c'est un
appareil de massage vous voyez il ya
plusieurs moyens de l'utiliser sur le
dos la jambe et même un peu plus haut
[Musique]
voilà ma spécialité poisson pané aux
graines de sésame et à la farine
complète
[Musique]
c'est comme dans james bond on a plein
de trucs rigolos comme ça la plateforme
de you a inauguré en 2010 c'est l'une
des toutes dernières installations
offshore sur le 450 présente en mer du
nord
imaginez un mastodonte de la superficie
d'un terrain de football
posé sur l'eau jour après jour nuit
après nuit
la plateforme complet réserves en
pétrole et en gaz contenu sous le fond
de la mer
un gisement estimé à 40 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz et 81 3 millions de
barils de pétrole
un vrai trésor
l'or noir norvégien depuis la découverte
des premiers gisements en mer du nord à
la fin des années 60
l'économie du pays s'est métamorphosée
gaz et pétrole génère aujourd'hui plus
du quart des revenus du pays en à peine
30 ans la norvège s'est glissé dans le
classement des états les plus riches du
monde
[Musique]
aéroport de floro à l'ouest de la
norvège c'est aujourd'hui la fin des
vacances pour accueillir hoofstadt
[Musique]
il est technicien sur la plateforme
et ce n'est pas l'air marin de la mer du
nord qui explique son bronzage mais
plutôt les quatre semaines qu'il vient
de passer dans les alpes
car travailler sur la plateforme c'est
d'abord cela quatre semaines de vacances
pour deux semaines de boulot c'est sur
les vacances seront terminées quelle je
reviens de quatre semaines de ski en
italie et maintenant pour pouvoir les
payer il faut retourner travailler
c'est partie pour quatorze jours de
boulot
sa collègue in good est aussi du voyage
sur une plateforme les réglementations
sont très strictes premières
restrictions
le portable pour éviter les risques
d'explosion les téléphones sont tout
simplement interdits offshore l'alcool
est également prohibé et gare à celui
qui n'est pas strictement 1,0 g la
plateforme est située à 60 km au large
l'hélicoptère est donc l'unique moyen
pour s'y rendre chacun doit donc enfilé
une combinaison qui lui permettra de
gagner quelques heures de survie en cas
de crash ça permet de rester au chaud et
en sécurité
si jamais d'hélicoptères tombe à l'eau
ils sont aujourd'hui une quinzaine à
rejoindre la plate forme de yoann
dernier briefing de sécurité avant de
monter dans l'hélicoptère
[Musique]
la sécurité c'est l'obsession des
travailleurs offshore une plate forme
c'est à la fois un lieu de travail un
lieu de vie et une bombe potentielle
pour avoir le droit du travail et chacun
a dû suivre une formation de survie en
haute mer le bo y est
le bo zied se passe en écosse à aberdeen
dans un centre de formation spécialisée
au programme extinction d'un cent dix
exercices d'évacuation hélitreuillage
initiation aux premiers secours
j'ai dit que ce n'était pas une course
les gars même si je vois bien que vous y
mettez du coeur ici la température de
l'eau est de 26 degrés ça équivaut à un
climat tropical sans mer du nord
on parle de températures qui dépassent
rarement les 10,2 à n'importe quelle
époque de l'année pour la mairie sage
forcé mais l'exercice le plus
spectaculaire attention accrochez-vous
c'est la simulation de crash en
hélicoptère les formateurs ou concocté
un scénario catastrophe
un amerrissage d'urgence l'hélicoptère
qui coule et même le retournement de la
cabine pour les stagiaires frissons
garantis
ils doivent rester attachés en attendant
que l'hélicoptère soit totalement
immobilisé après dix secondes sous l'eau
on se détache et peuvent s'échapper mais
si je te vois c'est le pire scénario
possible
effectivement c'est sympa les stagiaires
doivent être prêts pourtant à faire face
à toute éventualité
[Musique]
la panique est le pire ennemi c'est elle
qui causent le plus de décès avec cette
formation les stagiaires seront comment
se comporter en cas de crash
ils seront surtout un petit peu moins
paniqués
les stagiaires ont de 20 à 65 ans chaque
année ils sont trente mille à s'inscrire
à cette formation
le bose y est un diplôme valable quatre
ans qui leur permettra de travailler sur
toutes les plateformes du monde
le coma
retour en norvège pour hatlo le bo dietz
est déjà loin cela fait 26 ans qu'ils
travaillent offshore pour lui et ses
collègues rejoindre la plateforme en
hélicoptère c'est un petit peu comme
pour nous prendre le bus pour aller au
boulot pour at love is gone et tous les
autres c'est parti pour deux semaines de
travail intensif à raison de 12 heures
par jour
[Musique]
la plate forme de yoann ne repose pas
sur les fonds marins
en réalité elle flotte comme un bateau
retenu par 16 ans craint la coque a été
fabriquée en corée du sud est livrée en
norvège au terme d'un périple de 50
jours escorté par une frégate de l'armée
un convoi sacrément exceptionnel
la coque a ensuite été assemblés avec la
partie supérieure puis ouvrage
transporter vers le large
jusqu'au gisement sous la mer plusieurs
raccordement permettent d'aspirer les
réserves qui sont contenus deux
kilomètres plus bas
une fois remonté gaz et pétrole sont
séparés avant d'être envoyé sur la terre
ferme par pipe line
en tout il a fallu pas moins de 18
millions d'heures de travail et 4,5
milliards d'euros d'investissements pour
réaliser cet ouvrage
[Musique]
à peine arrivé et déjà la nouvelle
équipe doit se remettre au travail at le
lui à son petit rituel prendre le pouls
de yoann pendant deux heures ils
arpentent minutieusement la plateforme
pour y détecter la moindre anomalie un
bruit une odeur suspecte at l'heure
était déjà là à la construction des
équipements alors ses étages de
tuyauterie ses pompes ces compresseurs
il les connaît mieux que quiconque
[Applaudissements]
le monde
quand vous revenez après quatre semaines
à terre c'est important de vous
remémorer le bruit des machines
je passe donc des heures à déambuler
pour sentir la plateforme
il faut observer entendre et toucher
d'ailleurs là je sens les vibrations du
compresseur
bon évidemment on a un système
électronique pour contrôler les
vibrations mais je préfère ma bonne
vieille méthode
bonjour bonjour ça va bras pour passe
bien oui ça commence à se stabiliser là
nous sommes dans la salle de contrôle
c'est ici que sont compilés toutes les
informations techniques transmises par
les machines
une salle high tech qui permet aussi de
contrôler les 50 de caméras présentes
sur le site
on peut surtout visualiser en temps réel
les quantités d'hydrocarbures qui sont
envoyées à terre là on peut voir la
quantité de gaz produit en ce moment on
est à 13,7 millions de mètres cubes par
jour
mais on peut monter à 15.5 et pour le
pétrole pour le pétrole on produit 575
non 580 de mètres cubes par heure ça
c'est le tableau d'arrêt d'urgence si on
a une grosse alerte qui ne peut arrêter
toute la plate forme facilement était
juste en appuyant sur ce bouton est la
plateforme stoppe son activité en toute
sécurité
j'ai travaillé sur une autre plate forme
ou un petit curieux a voulu voir ce que
ça faisait d'appuyer sur le bouton la
plateforme s'est arrêté et lui est
rentré chez lui il a été viré
oui et il est revenu
jamais sur ok on a compris on évite
d'appuyer sur le bouton sur de la visite
la pièce la plus sensible c'est la salle
de réunion de crise
et on a pas mal d'équipements
sophistiqués dans cette pièce dont par
exemple
c'est un des buts est une
vidéoconférence c'est comme dans james
bond on a plein de trucs rigolos comme
ça chez darwin nord vous voyez la vitre
derrière vous
on ceux qui ne veulent pas être dérangés
on peut occulter la vitre voilà oui oui
je vois le genre avec le peu james bond
sur you à un homme à un poste clé arild
iund l'off shore install etienne manager
comprenait le chef de la plate forme
c'est le mélange entre le capitaine du
bateau et le directeur de l'usiné
le mur blanc que vous avez devant vous
c'est un mur anti explosion il empêche
le feu de se propager au quartier de huy
où nous sommes de l'autre côté du mur
vous avez toutes les machines et c'est
un maître ce traité les hydrocarbures
de notre côté évidemment il n'ya pas
d'hydrocarbures les hydrocarbures puiser
directement sous la mer transitent par
ces tuyaux sont traités sur la
plateforme et repartent par ce que l'on
appelle ryser c'est ici que les
hydrocarbures quitte la plate forme en
ce moment on exporte à peu près 85 mille
barils de pétrole et 15 millions et demi
de mètres cubes de gaz par jour et ce
pour un montant de 11 millions et demi
d'euros
ça fait une sacrée somme
[Musique]
si les hommes accède à la plateforme par
hélicoptère les marchandises le matériel
et l'eau sont acheminés par container un
bateau ravitailleur le 6 10 suply a fait
la navette deux fois par semaine si la
météo le permet justement aujourd'hui le
navire a pu se rapprocher au plus près
de la plate forme
il faut donc y charger les précieuses
caisse c'est la périlleuse mission
d'accueil le grutier inspection du
mécanisme des poulies et il faut faire
vite car en pleine mer du nord le temps
peut changer en quelques minutes
[Musique]
cdc des soupes lier à yoann est debout
près première opération vitale pour la
plateforme le raccordement en eau dans
les cuves du sinistre player 165 mètres
cubes d'eau potable qui vont servir aux
opérations techniques au nettoyage mais
aussi aux douches et à la cuisine
ah koon doit maintenant charger les
containers nourriture vêtements fion le
produit chimique matériel et poubelles
une opération délicate si les vagues
dépasse les 8 mètres de haut le bateau
devra quitter la zone pour éviter tout
risque de collision avec la plateforme
[Musique]
il faut suivre le mouvement des vagues
et ça peut vite devenir très compliqué
car la plateforme bouge et le bateau
latéralement mais aussi de haut en bas
évidemment on élite d'écraser son petit
camarade sur le pont qui est il non
papier tilly qui est il chez son prénom
il est là pour réceptionner les caisses
de plusieurs tonnes c'est tout l'amitié
d'arrivée a bien aligné les conteneurs
si les compteurs sont séparés les uns
des autres ils peuvent glisser sur le
pont sous l'effet des vagues
c'est aussi plus jolie de les aligner
bien droit un brin maniaque un petit peu
comme un tetris géant
les containers sont à peine posé qu'il
faut déjà les décharger tous là la
cuisinière et alpha le responsable de
l'approvisionnement ont une curieuse
manière de faire leur marché
ces deux là sont plus à l'aise derrière
des fourneaux mais sur une plate forme
il faut savoir tout faire surtout qu'ici
on ne compte pas vraiment les quantités
en g tuna et half vont décharger trois
tonnes de nourriture
aujourd'hui nous avons un deux trois
quatre 4 containers ont été toujours
excitant de découvrir ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur c'est un peu noël mais c'est
ça tout dépendra dit c'est noël
néanmoins chaque semaine l'équipage
consomme en moyenne 10 kg de sucre 50 kg
de pommes de terre et plus de 170 litres
de lait et bien sûr les extras et voilà
les bonbons je voyais ça on utilise tout
le temps ce crochet est vital pour nous
ça évite à la porte de se refermer sur
nous si la plateforme bouge trop donc on
doit toujours accroché la porte
en hiver la mauvaise météo peut empêcher
le bateau de venir dans ce cas là on
doit attendre la semaine suivante week
c'est pour ça qu'on a un stock de
nourriture très important dans nos
réserves
et voilà qu'il est presque 19 heures
tout à l'heure tous nos doigts
maintenant troqué sa combinaison de
chantier pour son tablier de chef
non là je m'apprête à servir le dîner
fin c'est excellent on sert d'abord ceux
de l'équipe de nuit qui commencent leur
journée à 100 ensuite le reste de
l'équipage jeunes radiner à cette heure
150 bienvenue dans la cuisine de you au
menu aujourd'hui avec le traditionnel
norvégien et ça compte c'est le comble
avec des runs bolatti tout l'équipage en
raffole le resterai au met
le couple est une institution en norvège
un plat de fête
enfin réservé aux estomacs les plus
solides pour les petites faims préféré
ces crudités fraîchement coupés ou
encore ses fruits de mer et puis pour
les gourmands les gâteaux du chef tuna
doit satisfaire tous les appétits
c'est un casse tête quotidien c'est très
important de varier les menus
quand je reste ici deux semaines je dois
prévoir au moins 14
la base de viande et 14h à base de pois
chiches presse dalila ça c'est le
poisson qu'ils m'appellent
investissement s pêche alors été ebola
ma spécialité c'est sam c'est le poisson
pané aux graines de sésame et à la
farine complète l'équipe de nuit vient
de terminer son petit déjeuner quand
l'équipe de jour se présentent au
réfectoire la cuisine fonctionne 24
heures sur 24
ils sont deux chefs à se relayer nuit et
jour pour nourrir tout le monde
les repas tiennent une place toute
particulière sur une plateforme
ils permettent de garder le moral de
l'équipe au plus haut le repas
contribuer au bien-être collectif à bord
d'une plateforme
c'est important pour tout le monde de
bien manger que de mai un bon repas donc
mais avaler rapidement 15 20 minutes car
la plateforme elle ne fait jamais de
pause
[Musique]
à la nuit tombée un seul homme ose
s'aventurer dans les entrailles du
monstre
yann tories l infirmier de you à sa
mission tester la qualité de l'eau qui
vient d'être livré à bord et s'assurer
qu'elle n'a pas été contaminée pendant
le voyage
cela se passe à l'intérieur même de la
coque
là on descend directement dans la coque
à 20 mètres sous la surface de l'eau
sous la mer vraiment oui sous la mer
nous voilà donc dans un des piliers de
la plateforme
la coque contient trois énormes
réservoirs chacun d'eux équivaut à deux
semaines de réserves en eau pour tout
l'équipage
l'eau est vitale à tous les niveaux si
nous n'avons plus d'eau nous devons
ramener les gens à terre et arrêter la
production
tout est lié des échantillons en poche
direction l'infirmerie
il s'agit à présent de vérifier
l'acidité de l'eau et sa teneur en
chlore pour garantir qu'elle soit
potable car une intoxication collective
montrait la plateforme en péril dernier
test et pas des moindres je la goutte
bien sûr c'est comme du vin alain sacré
bouquet je suis descendu prendre des
échantillons dans le réservoir b alors
celui là est certifié l'eau et chlorés
et potable donc tu peux le mettre en
service c'est ok
aux claques en tant qu'infirmier yann un
rôle clé sur yoann s'il doit prévenir
les accidents avant de les soigner
il a quand même de quoi parer à toutes
les éventualités offshore quand on vit
sur une plateforme
on fait de notre mieux pour soigner le
patient plutôt que de le renvoyer à
terre onshore donc ici on a bien plus de
médicaments que nécessaire parce qu'on
cherche à résoudre le problème sur place
ça coûte moins cher que de ramener le
malade à terre
[Musique]
malgré cela il arrive parfois qu'un
événement familial oblige un équipier à
rentrer en urgence à la maison accident
décès d'un membre de la famille c'est
souvent à l'infirmier que l'on s'adresse
pour en parler
yann peut décider alors de le rapatrier
à terre avb et good bad et je dois à la
fois être un bon copain et un chef de
puisque je suis dans l'équipe dirigeante
mais je suis surtout infirmiers oms en
os dans des collègues viennent me parler
de leur vie personnelle je les écoute et
je les conseille et come to me ayo à
l'ambiance est très bonne c'est comme
une famille je connais bien tout le
monde leurs bons comme leurs mauvais
côtés
[Musique]
7h30 pour sté narvik le mécanicien la
pause a été courte et la journée n'est
pas finie
un dernier petit café avant de retrouver
le vacarme assourdissant des machines
[Musique]
notre mécanicien et son équipe doivent
intervenir sur le tuyau d'exportation du
pétrole et en remplacer l'une de ses
pièces maîtresses cet appareil calcule
le débit et la quantité précise de
pétrole exportés chaque jour c'est un
peu la caisse enregistreuse de la
plateforme
[Musique]
mais on se doit de connaître exactement
la quantité de pétrole qu'on vend c'est
comme à la station essence
quand vous faites un plein de 50 litres
vous voulez être sûr d'avoir réellement
50 litres d'essence dans votre réservoir
c'est la même chose pour nous sa ligne
directement
une pièce d'autant plus cruciale qu'elle
permet de savoir exactement le prix à
payer pour l'acheteur un pourcentage
d'erreurs même un film peut entraîner
des pertes colossales
rappelez-vous que yoann exporte chaque
jour l'équivalent de 85 mille barils de
brut
un pourcentage d'erreur de seulement 0 5
% représente une perte nette de 35 mille
euros par jour c'est beaucoup d'argent
il faut donc la re calibrer tous les ans
et pendant ce temps là évidemment la
production elle continue comme les
shadoks pas question d'arrêter le pomper
quand une équipe travaille sur le
circuit principal
le flux de pétrole et dérivés vers un
circuit secondaire
en grand professionnel spénard ne vais
jamais de lire les instructions de
sécurité et en français s'il vous plaît
on n'a pas des menteurs sur gazon
mais les portes
moi je ne me moque pas de votre accent
ce que je ne sait déjà pas prononcer
votre nom alors
[Musique]
6h30 une petites mains s'affairent déjà
ne vous fiez pas à son air poupin
derrière ce sourire ravageur se cache
une pitoyable chasseuse de bactéries
tous les matins annette berg promène son
chiffon antistatique dans les vestiaires
de la plateforme
là je suis tranquille je vais avoir
cette pièce pour moi tout seul pendant
une demi heure
ils sont tous en réunion et il ne
commence pas avant 7h twins à cannes 2
alors je vais pouvoir tout nettoyer et
du nettoyage
il y en a annette a toujours un endroit
à briquet elles ne sont que deux pour
nettoyer les 3600 mètres carrés de
quartiers d'habitation que compte la
plateforme
pas question donc de chemin et après les
parties communes annette s'attaque au
linge des 63 membres d'équipage chacun
son petit sac diminue
ils ont tous leur numéro de chambre
écrit sur leurs sacs dans qu'ils peuvent
facilement retrouver leurs affaires
après on met les vêtements propres ici
il suffit de retrouver le bon numéro
si vous habitez la chambre cats et votre
sac vous êtes un peu leur nounou ils
sont comme mes enfants
une nounou d'enfer au milieu des mères
mais dites-moi net pourquoi avoir choisi
ce mode de vie si particulier c'est un
travail très bien payé au fil du temps j
ai appris beaucoup de choses et je ne
voudrais pas en changer je n'ai pas fait
d'études qui me permettent de gagner
autant à terre j'ai une maison un bateau
beaucoup de frais et donc pas question
que je quitte ce boulot mais un salaire
deux fois supérieur peut-il vraiment
compenser l'éloignement du conjoint
en fait c'est plutôt positif pour la
vidéo c'est être capable de partir faire
un break en deux semaines mais je sais
aussi qu'il me manque
quand je suis ici et ça c'est bon signe
ce garde fou mais je n'appelle pas
beaucoup à la maison quand je suis sur
you and i don't car ça me donne le
cafard mettront parfois mon copain me
reproche de ne pas assez appelé à la
maison et je lui réponds qu'il me manque
trop je préfère rester focalisé sur mon
travail
oui le travail certes mais la déco aussi
non un âne est une
il n'ya que des femmes qui travaillent
ici tous les garçons des photos de
femmes nues dans leur bulle nous aussi
on a demandé à avoir des photos d'hommes
nus et on a obtenu celui là
direction le deuxième étage en tout la
plateforme dispose de 100 chambres
individuelles kenneth doit entretenir
régulièrement et elle a accepté de nous
ouvrir la porte d'une de ces cabines
tout confort
[Musique]
propre évidemment vue sur mer chauffage
au sol téléphone écran de télé bienvenue
au yoyo à palas rien ne manque
sauf peut-être un peu le lit king size
les cabines ont toutes la même taille et
tout le monde a la même les chefs les
cuisinières les femmes de ménage et même
le patron de la plateforme est ici pas
de jaloux tous ont droit en prime à une
salle de bain individuelle avec lavabos
douches et toilettes un luxe sur une
plateforme où l'espace est si précieux
aucune plateforme c'est très difficile
d'être seul qu'on aille entendent
toujours sur quelqu'un c'est vraiment
bien d'avoir une chambre à soi on doit
parfois à la fin de la journée on a
juste envie de s'affaler tout seul dans
sa chambre
nous on a de l'intimité même si ces
minuscules ans mort on a compris c'est
un peu l'hôtel ici
[Musique]
bienvenue au bureau de liaison de you à
un hôtel qui a même sa petite boutique
ici on a toutes sortes de choses
indispensables du déodorant tout près du
dentifrice des brosses à dents des
rasoirs des préservatifs
non ben non mais je pense que
l'infirmier en a si vous en avez besoin
fumer on a même des trucs pour les
filles
on a des tee-shirts on a des sous
vêtements des produits donc de première
nécessité mais aussi des sucreries en
cas d'oubli alpha de quoi parer au plus
pressé
un peu comme le concierge d'un grand
hôtel là il ya le tableau avec toutes
les cabines en ce moment il ya soixante
trois personnes à bord il reste 37
cabine vide
c'est un peu comme une réception d'hôtel
mais un hôtel un peu particulier au lieu
de vous remettre une clé half vous
confie ce drôle de boîtiers c'est un
système qui permet de vous localiser
que vous soyez sur la plateforme oui
tout le monde en a autour du cou quand
vous passez sous un récepteur ça vous
enregistrez là on peut voir sur
l'ordinateur qui fait quoi
en ce moment vous avez sept personnes
dans la partie production en rouge et 54
dans la partie habitation en verre il ya
deux personnes qui sont descendus dans
la coque une chose
bon ce système de traceurs ce n'est pas
non plus big brother il ne sert qu en
cas d'évacuation d'urgence pour
localiser les travailleurs qui sont
dispersés aux quatre coins de la plate
forme car il ya toujours une porte à
vérifier une lampe a changé
et côté production c'est la même chose
dans la salle de contrôle
ac le énigmes prépare une opération de
maintenance qu'ils vont réaliser dans la
journée et comme à chaque fois ils sont
deux on doit préparer une pompe pour une
opération mécanique
il faut fermer le circuit et le purger
avec de l'eau on va vérifier celui là et
voir si on peut le coupé on est toujours
à deux sur ce type d'opérations comme ça
chacun vérifie le travail de l'autre
castor à 2 au moins on est sûr tu es
prête à y aller mais les dégâts
le travail en binôme c'est ce qui a
séduit in good qui vit à you à sa toute
première expérience offshore
elle fait figure d'exception dans cet
univers principalement un masculin sur
la plateforme
seuls 10 % des travailleurs sont des
femmes
pour s'imposer in good a dû faire sa
place
sa taxe parfois je suis obligé d'appeler
un homme à la rescousse
j'ai besoin de gros bras tu peux m'aider
plutôt que d'aller à la gym mais on peut
venir travailler ici
[Musique]
et ils ne sont pas trop de deux pour se
repérer dans ce méli-mélo de vannes à
ouvrir ou à fermer une fois le circuit
de la pompe isolés ils vont pouvoir la
purger en toute sécurité
[Musique]
mais dites nous attelons elle pas où
toute cette eau n'est pas directement
jetés à la mer
c'est important de le dire c'est tout va
dans un réservoir
on a deux gros réservoir pour stocker
les eaux sales on doit d'abord la
nettoyer et seulement après les rejeter
à la mer
oui
on peut donc travailler dans le pétrole
et avoir le souci de l'environnement bio
à est d'ailleurs un modèle en la matière
là où les autres plateformes doivent
brûler le pétrole qu'elle extrait pour
créer leur électricité
yoann a fait venir de terre grâce à un
câble sous marin de 100 km bilan une
substantielle réduction de ses émissions
en co2 une plateforme verte en quelque
sorte enfin vers clair pour un gone est
apte le la journée se termine
il est temps de repasser côté habitation
pour échapper au confinement de la
plateforme et pour évacuer le stress
rien de tel qu'un peu de sport diot à
dispose de deux salles de sport
suréquipés on oublierait presque qu'on
est au milieu de la mer du nord
[Musique]
et voilà in gones la reine du hula hoop
cette passionnée de ce qui peut enfin
rêver de grand espace sur petit écran
just je fais 30 minutes de hula-hoop
regardant des vidéos de ski ski oui des
os ça me permet de m'évader un peu ouais
[Musique]
de son côté as tu le a décidé de
s'isoler à sa manière la plateforme et
reliés à la fibre optique qui lui permet
de dialoguer avec sa famille par
internet
j'aurais bien aimé avoir la nouvelle
avant de partir pour lui c'est une
journée un peu spéciale
il vient d'apprendre qu'il est devenu
grand père pendant la nuit ils
découvrent enfin les premières images de
sa petite fille andréa approche la plus
près de la caméra
ça fait partie des moments où on
préférait travailler à terre évidemment
j'ai envie d'être là avec eux mais c'est
comme ça tu as toi et laisse quand je
rentre à la maison
j'ai plein de temps à consacrer à mes
enfants et c'était pareil quand mes deux
fils était tout petit j'avais beaucoup
de temps pour eux quand j'étais à la
maison
contrairement à mes amis qui travaillent
normalement je jouais avec que j'allais
au jardin d'enfants avec eux tout conte
fait je pense que c'est mieux pour les
enfants
7 heures le lendemain matin la journée
d'art hilde le chef de la plate forme
commence par un briefing de ses équipes
au programme météo et café noir pour les
plus endormis à quelques-uns à ril de
lui est sur le pont depuis au moins une
heure et ce n'est pas fini
il doit ensuite animé la visioconférence
quotidienne avec la terre ferme
bonjour les cas je pense que c'est pas
très bon d'écumé la cuve de dégazage en
continu vaut mieux la laisser reposer et
reprendre l'opération ensuite à terre 75
personnes s'occupent du soutien
logistique de l'équipe de johan on a
vraiment besoin d'avoir un dialogue
productif avec chaque jour car ils nous
aident à résoudre les problèmes qu'on
peut rencontrer
c'est très important nutri eux aussi
bien sûr ils ont besoin de savoir
comment ça se passe à bord
et voilà dimanche sur you as le rituel
dominical
c'est le grand nettoyage des ponts le
travail est réparti en équipe tout le
moment il participe tout le monde même
le chef il n'hésite pas à mettre les
mains dans le cambouis
c'est bon pour le moral de toute
l'équipe il ya un véritable aspect
social
ça permet de mieux connaître ceux avec
qui on n'a pas forcément l'habitude de
travailler
ar il destine à récurent les
canalisations in bloom et atl se
chargent de petites fuites d'huile sous
les machines un vrai travail collectif
qui va prendre plus d'une heure
on a tous envie d'avoir une plateforme
bien propre donc on s'y met tous pendant
une heure
c'est comme pour votre maison vous
l'aimez propre sang détritus qui
traînent partout
c'est pareil pour nous et après l'effort
le réconfort place à l'instant saucisses
arrosé comme il se doit de bière enfin
sans alcool à stocker le hot dog
c'est la récompense la carotte shopping
le nettoyage ça permet à chacun de se
sentir responsable de yoann du patron à
la femme de ménage tout le monde comme
un coup de main dans les dédales de la
plateforme
les techniciens peuvent passer des
journées entières sans se croiser ces
moments de convivialité permet de souder
les équipes de créer un esprit de corps
bon appétit si un problème intervient
sur you are ils sauront réagir et
s'entraider
mais c'est harry lde qui devra prendre
l'ultime décision évacuer la plateforme
voici les trois canots de sauvetage de
jumeaux sont inclinés pour pouvoir
traverser l'eau et en équipage de plus
loin possible de la plate forme saas et
la zone de rassemblement avec l'entrée
des canaux
acoss tout le monde se réunit ici dès
que l'alarmé sonne en tant que capitaine
je suis le dernier à quitter la
plateforme
alors quand j'arrive ici j'appuie sur
ses deux boutons qui coupent toute
l'activité de yum après je rejoins mon
canot de sauvetage
le mien c'est numéro 2 je place mon
badge ici et le système de
radiofréquence nous reconnaît la lumière
verte s'allume et mon nom apparaît ici
[Musique]
10/06 bon les canaux sauvetage ne sont
pas très confortable mais c'est un
excellent moyen d'évacuation
spécialement conçu pour les plateformes
pétrolières ces canots de sauvetage sont
capables de traverser une nappe de
pétrole en feu après un plongeon de 20
mètres dans l'eau glacée de la mer du
nord
en bon capitaine arild a la lourde
responsabilité de donner l'ordre
d'évacuation au risque d'abandonner
peut-être des hommes derrière lui si
quelqu'un manque à l'appel et que seul à
mettre en danger
il ya toujours un dilemme beaucoup
évidemment il faut évaluer s'il est
possible de tout faire pour retrouver
celui qui manque comme malgré le danger
pour les autres je sais que c'est un
dilemme que je devrais résoudre si
jamais cela arrive c'est adam mais bon
il faudra bien prendre une décision
à la nuit tombée après douze heures de
labeur chacun peut profiter des loisirs
disponibles sur la plate forme et ils
sont nombreux
allez enfin petit tour du propriétaire
l'ex thénard le mécanisme même si on
travaille beaucoup il y aura au minimum
douze heures par jour
on a pas mal de moyens d'occuper les
quelques heures qui nous reste on peut
se retrouver dans cette salle pour jouer
aux cartes on a une petite bibliothèque
avec plein de livres box et on a une
sélection de journaux des magazines
people à la décoration intérieure il y
en a pour tous les goûts
oui m'enfin visiblement la déco
d'intérieur c'est pas trop d'autre qu'un
stannard 14 jours sur une plate forme
c'est pour les longues nuits en
solitaire ouais mais ces magazines ne
sont pas censés quitter la bibliothèque
voilà et pour les passionnés
d'informatique la plateforme offre de
parfaits défouloir vnx d'accord sur une
plateforme on a besoin de geek you est
tellement high tech qu'on ne pourrait
pas la faire marcher sans eux ils sont
indispensables au mend
et voilà la machine à bronzer même l'été
on peut jamais bronzé dehors parce que
dès que vous quittez la partie
habitation vous devez porter un casque
des lunettes de sécurité et une
combinaison donc pas de bronzage naturel
même s'il fait grand soleil et bien sûr
les fans du septième art ne sont pas
lésés une salle de cinéma de 50 places
est à leur disposition et les sièges
sont rétractables
ils permettent de dégager assez d'espacé
pour installer par exemple un hôpital
d'urgence
ces pratiques non on a un écran géant
avec un excellent vidéoprojecteur qu'ils
utilisent les mêmes à hollywood ça vaut
très cher des équipements donc dernier
cri et en bon meccanos thénard peut
s'adonner à son passe temps favori
le rallye automobile et oui nos
travailleurs offshore souverain guetta
on a besoin de tous ses équipements pour
casser un peu la routine quotidienne sur
une plate forme c'est tout un style de
vie je me suis habitué à travailler ici
pendant deux semaines d'affilée et j'ai
tout ce qu'il me faut il ne me manque
rien
dernier détour dans les méandres de
yoann stener nous guide vers un lieu
très privé et là c'est la salle de
musique
à côté de ces armoires électriques qui
commande tout la plateforme surprise un
set complet d'instruments de musique
[Musique]
laissez moi vous présenter à la batterie
au ringo starr quelques étages plus
l'eau la croisière s'amuse le reste de
l'équipage s'est réuni pour le
traditionnel bingo hebdomadaire
le gagnant du jour repart avec un
appareil de massage dernier cri c'est un
appareil de massage vous voyez il ya
plusieurs moyens de l'utiliser sur le
dos la jambe et même un peu plus au
sénat lui ni massage ils les préfèrent à
6 j'aime bien profiter du siège de
massage
après une longue journée de travail à
longuenesse
c'est super confortable
[Musique]
à
avant de quitter yoa arild a tenu à nous
emmener dans un endroit plein de
promesses ça ce sont des raccordements
pour le futur de new york
on espère tout ce qu'on croit encore
plus de pétrole dans les environs et que
tous ces raccordements seront utilisés
un jour on espère pouvoir doubler la
durée de vie de la plateforme pour
qu'elle dure encore 30 ans c'est à la
fois notre but est notre rêve à tous
[Musique]
pour yann d'imphy relier cette à présent
l'heure du départ l'hélicoptère qui
amènent des équipes de relève vient de
se poser il ya ne va pouvoir retrouver
sa femme et ses enfants et sa donné
pendant quatre semaines à sa grande
passion la pêche
une aubaine il faut vous rappeler que
deux semaines ici ça représente 160 2
heures de travail
c'est l'équivalent d'un mois on
travaille dur quand on est sur la
plateforme
donc on est content de rentrer à la
maison et de se reposer un peu yan
england ac le et tous les autres la
volontiers ne changerais de métier pour
rien au monde
malgré le risque omniprésent malgré l'
isolement parfois pesant ils ont trouvé
un équilibre dans ce mode de vie si
singulier ils savent aussi que le fruit
de leur travail bénéficiera à leurs
enfants car l'état norvégien verse une
partie des revenus du pétrole de yoann
dans un fonds d'investissement souverain
pour les générations futures
[Musique]